what if I were to tell you that I'm not  even a human being and what you see is  not real that was actually a deep fake  now deep fakes might seem like a  harmless joke but any technology can be  used for evil I genuinely love the  process of manipulating people online  for money have you ever been watching a  video and suspected that it might be  fake and that the person in the video is  not who he claims to be try playing the  video super slowly The Mask will blur  and you'll see a glitch not sure who  you're talking to in a video chat ask  your partner to turn his head to the  side or hold his hand in front of his  face the mask will glitch remember these  tips and share with your friends if you  found this video useful